[Musique]
les rois de france ont toujours connu
des périodes de stabilité comme de cris
si la situation avait pu revenir un
équilibre louis saez roi bourbon
n'aurait pas été surnommé de façon
dérisoire
louis le dernier on l'a élevée en lisant
vous êtes un monarque de droit divin
vous serez un monarque de droit divin
vous régnerait comme un monarque de
droit divin
donc on lui avait pas laissé miroiter
qu'un jour ou l'autre il faudra qu'il
change son fusil d épaule
c'est bien qu'il n'a pas été en mesure
de le faire
[Musique]
c'est sous son règne que la catastrophe
qui avait prédit de son grand-père des
années auparavant en porte à la
monarchie plusieurs facteurs
déstabilisants contribuer déjà à créer
un climat politique agité sous en
quelque sorte dans cette population
française le désir de changement de
renouveau de vie qualité mais quand
louis saez se montra incapable d'assurer
la paix à l'intérieur de son état une
tempête éclate art qui renversa la
monarchie et entraîna la révolution
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quand il monta sur le trône le pays
était profondément endetté l'injustice
et la pauvreté régnait les changements
de la société française et l'esprit des
lumières rendait inévitable la révision
des anciennes structures politiques
de plus l'autorité de la monarchie
française avait été mise en cause par
une alliance diplomatique controversée
louis 15 choc à toute l'europe
en signant un traité avec l'autriche
siège du saint-empire romain germanique
les deux pays étaient en lutte depuis
huit siècles cette promesse d'amitié fut
scellée par un mariage royal
le petit fils de louis 15 louis auguste
et la fille de l'impératrice marie
antonia de habsbourg archiduchesse
d'autriche furent informés que l'avenir
de leur pays respectif reposait sur le
succès de cette union
mais nul ne se doutait à quel point
c'était vrai
[Musique]
louis auguste de france futur louis saez
était né au château de versailles le 23
août 1754 il avait alors reçu le titre
de duc de berry
il était le second fils du dauphin de
france louis ferdinand et de son épouse
marie josèphe de saxe ce qui faisait de
lui le petit fils du roi louis 15 durant
sa petite enfance
louis auguste fut le second d'une
fratrie composée de quatre garçons et
une fille
son frère aîné était louis joseph ducs
de bourgogne
les plus jeunes étaient ses deux frères
louis stanislas comtes de provence
charles philippe comte d'artois et sa
soeur la princesse clotilde la princesse
elisabeth 20 compléter la famille quand
louis auguste avait presque dix ans
à versailles
toutes les attentions étaient tournés
vers le fils aîné bel enfant précoce et
premier dans la succession au trône
après son père mais le jeune prince bien
aimé mourut de la tuberculose à l'âge de
9 ans la même maladie emporte a ensuite
ses parents ce qui fit de louis auguste
jusque là négligé le prétendant au trône
il avait alors onze louis saez s'est
toujours cru indigne d'eux se ferait et
la bmc peu l'impression d'avoir usurpé
sa place d'autant plus que ses parents
n'avaient pas à son égard beaucoup
témoigné d'affection
si louis auguste coni dans l'enfance des
carences affectives il eu une
adolescence bien remplie sur le plan
intellectuel
entouré par les nombreux membres de la
famille royale
il aimait la compagnie de son grand père
avec qui il allait chasser de ses trois
tentes et de ses quatre frères et soeurs
comme il est appelé un jour à renier on
a tout un tas de pédagogue autour de lui
qui sont des gens brillants mais
extrêmement conservateur extrêmement
religieux donc il n'a droit à aucune
incartade mais il est très consciencieux
il adore la géographie il adore la
diplomatie et il adore aussi le
bricolage enfin c'est pour l'instant
c'est un c'est un petit jeune homme avec
une tête bien faite et une tête bien
pleine
son éducation conservatrice dissimulait
un niveau intellectuel élevé il fut
instruit par deux professeurs
d'université
un éminent géographe et un pionnier de
la philologie qui le décrivent comme un
élève naturellement curieux et même doué
le dauphin possédait une excellente
mémoire montrait de grandes aptitudes en
mathématiques en sciences et en
géographie
ils s'intéressaient tout
particulièrement à l'histoire et à tout
ce qui se rapportait à la marine
il sait parler aux 1 4 langues
étrangères l'espagnol l'italien
l'allemand bien évidemment en plus du
latin c'est l'abbé nollet qui est son
professeur de physique c'est toujours
l'abbé nollet qui lui enseigne les
mathématiques il ira la bid
radonvilliers justement professeur de
langues il ya toute une série une
formation très très importante si vous
voulez qui va se se dérouler pendant de
très nombreuses années et la formation
donc que véritablement très solide on
peut dire peut-être même que à l'âge de
17 ans un 1016 et tout à fait
aujourd'hui comparable à un enfant ou un
adolescent plutôt qui criait dans une
école prépare par préparatoires pour une
grande école louis auguste avait la peau
blanche les cheveux blonds et de grands
yeux bleus comme son grand père c'était
un garçon de nature timide à qu'ils ont
appris qu'il ne fallait pas que les
autres puisse deviner ses pensées c'est
à cause de cela que l'on doute a parfois
de son intelligence
marie antoinette était née maria antonia
josefa johanna des apps pour le 2
novembre 1755 au palais de la hofburg à
vienne en autriche
madame antoine comme on l'appelait était
la plus jeune fille
la 15ème de ses enfants de
l'archiduchesse marie thérèse d'autriche
et de l'empereur françois 1er de
lorraine comme il y avait de nombreux
enfants avant elle madame antoine fut
quelque peu négligé par sa mère
elle avait de ce fait très peu
d'instruction à 12 ans c'est tout juste
si elle pouvait lire ou écrire
correctement dans sa langue maternelle
l'allemand elle est un petit peu
négligente elle préfère la musique elle
par même d'épouser mozart voilà elle est
un petit peu fanfaronne elle aime
s'amuser plutôt que d'apprendre si bien
qu'on est obligé de de lui donner des
professeurs strict parce qu'elle avait
une gouvernante qui recopiait elle même
les devoirs de la petite marie
antoinette pour qu'elle ne soit pas puni
pour ses nombreuses filles l'impératrice
marie thérèse projeta de former des
mariages d'alliance avec trois membres
de la maison de bourbon
quand une épidémie de variole ne lui
laissa plus que trois filles à marier la
plus âgée marie-amélie fut fiancée au
duc de parme et marie-caroline la soeur
préférée de la future dauphine de france
fut financé au roi de naples
la petite archiduchesse de 12 ans marie
antoinette était à présent la seule
fille ans est disponible pour le dauphin
de france louis auguste âgée de 14 ans
un tel mariage était sans précédent
le roi louis 15 qui envisage donc de
marier son petit-fils a contacté la cour
de trichet il a un accueil favorable
pourquoi parce que l'autriche et la
france tombe d'accord pour essayer de
contrecarrer un petit peu l'influent ce
qui devient de plus en plus considérable
en europe qui est celle de l'angleterre
est celle de la prusse
[Applaudissements]
la france va renouer son alliance avec
la puissance catholique de l'autriche
sous le règne de louis xiv pour éviter
un encerclement de l'espagne et du
saint-empire romain germanique
la france s'est donc rapproché des prix
des puissances protestants ce au grand
dam de voûte leur depuis deux siècles
la guerre avait jeté les unes contre les
autres ces grandes maisons européennes
mais les politiques expansionnistes des
super puissances émergentes
l'angleterre et la prusse obligeait une
france affaiblie à salir avec son ancien
ennemi
l'autriche les deux pays jurèrent de se
porter secours en cas d'agression il
s'agit de renforcer l'alliance entre la
france et l'autriche et marie-antoinette
devient en france le gage de l'alliance
franco autrichienne
contrairement à louis 15 l'impératrice
espérer davantage qu'une simple alliance
défensive
elle considérait sa fille comme un outil
est une extension de la politique
étrangère ces obligations étaient de
deux natures
elle devait produire un héritier mâle un
prince bourbon habsbourg concrétiserait
la réalité de cette alliance et l'on
attendait d'elle qu'elle met en avant
les intérêts directs de sa patrie à
travers son influence à la cour
madame antoine n'avait que 14 ans
lorsqu'elle quitte à vienne et fut
rebaptisé marie-antoinette dauphine de
france lors de la séparation
sa mère lui dit adieu ma chère enfant
nous allons être séparés par une grande
distance fait tant de bien au peuple
français qu'il puisse dire que je lui ai
envoyé un an
elle ne revit jamais sa mère ni vienne
l'archiduchesse fut officiellement
remises aux français le 7 mai 1770 en
territoire neutre sur l'île aux épices
au milieu du rhin ben oui 15 demande à
son conseiller bourg et qu'il avait
rencontré à vienne at elle de la gorge
et pour élever coûté majesté je ne
saurais vous le dire mais bourgoin dan
c'est la première chose qu'on regarde
chez une femme est donc le mariage raid
célébrer là on connaît la réflexion de
louis 15 le soir
le soir du repas de noce dix ans à louis
saez qui était un gros bas france était
un gros gourmands ils mangeaient
considérablement et lui dispense vers
lui en disant ne vous chargez pas trop
pour cette nuit et le futur petit louis
cesu mais pourquoi genre toujours mieux
quand j'ai bien mangé
donc la petite marie antoinette est tout
à fait bien accueilli on l'acclamé
l'applaudît parce qu'elle est belle elle
est souriante et en et raf
elle arriva au château de versailles
porteuses dé seule espérance de sa
famille ont célébré l'événement et le
peuple de france fut d'abord charmé par
la personnalité et la grande beauté de
marie antoinette
mais sous la surface couler un courant
de méfiance
ce seul mariage ne pouvait faire
disparaître dans la population des
siècle d'hostilité envers les habsbourg
qui était l'ennemi héréditaire de la
france
[Musique]
comme beaucoup de jeunes personnes royal
avant que le dauphin est la dauphine
connurent des difficultés a consommé
leur mariage
on pensait qu'en devenant adulte il
remet dirais au problème mais les années
passaient et aucun progrès ne se faisait
jour
la situation devient de plus en plus
tendues et embarrassante
on sait que louis saez un petit journal
de bord dans lequel il note des tas de
choses et le lendemain de sa demie noces
il note rien bon généralement ce carnet
indique le nombre de pièces de gibier
qu'il a pu lever ou traquer dans telle
ou telle forêt parce que c'était un un
grand chasseur devant l'éternel
mais néanmoins il ne s'est rien passé et
il ne va rien se passer pendant sept ans
à l'exception de leur manque
d'inclination envers le sexe louis et
marie antoinette avait peu de choses en
commun ce qui renforçait encore leurs
difficultés conjugales louis n'eut
jamais une allure royal le peuple disait
qu'on ne pouvait savoir qu'il était roi
quand on ne regardait en revanche marie
antoinette était le charme et l'élégance
personnifiée elle possédait une grâce
exquise
on disait qu elle flottait lorsqu'elle
marche est lui avait une grande capacité
de réflexion mais manquait de confiance
et de volonté dans l'action elle de son
côté n'avait aucun penchant pour les
matières scolaires mais ne craignait pas
de s'engager dans ce qu'elle désirait
il avait des idées plutôt conservatrice
alors qu'elle s'intéressait à l'avant
garde
il tenait ces émotions cachées elle
était une femme émotive est très
affectueuse
marie-antoinette malgré ces efforts ne
partagez pas la passion de louis pour la
chasse nice un penchant pour certains
passe-temps solitaire comme l'horlogerie
au cours de leur première année de
mariage la timidité du prince et leurs
grandes différences de tempérament
empêcha le couple de se rapprocher à la
mort du roi louis 15 en 1774 louis
auguste monta sur le trône de france
il devint le roi louis saez et
marie-antoinette reçu le titre de reine
consort de france l'influent ce que
pouvaient exercer une fille de l' empire
du mal alimentait les soupçons des
ennemis de l'autriche
même si marie antoinette déposséder
l'habileté de marie de médicis
elle n'aurait pu exercer la moindre
influence louis avait été prévenu en
permanence par son tuteur et ses
conseillers du danger qu'il courait en
permettant à son épouse autrichienne
d'exercer le moindre pouvoir politique
officielle ou non
la solitude ce mariage décevant
l'impossibilité de comblé les espérances
de sa famille et le formalisme rigide de
la cour de france conduisirent marie
antoinette à se tourner vers les gens et
les passions qui pouvait lui apporter
quelques réconforts elle trouva une
consolation à la cour auprès des enfants
auprès des animaux domestiques de
versailles et développa un penchant pour
les jardins anglais beaucoup moins
formelle que ceux à la française
l'échec du couple à concevoir un enfant
était stigmatisé par la publication de
pamphlets obscènes les libelles qui
raillait leur infertilité marie
antoinette se réfugia dans les
distractions la reine considéra bientôt
ses amis proches comme des membres de sa
famille le seul moyen pour elle
d'exercer une influence était le mécénat
elle fit venir de vienne à paris le
compositeur d'opéra a précédé habsburg
christophe glück on estime qu'elle a
largement contribué à révolutionner
l'opéra français dont la grande
popularité rejaillit sur elle la reine
passer ses nuits dans des fêtes
somptueuses elle ne buvait pas mais
devint obsédé par le jeu alors elle va
le passer ses soirées à jouer ses nuits
à jouer
olemps que neo biribi etc etc des tas de
jeux de société dans lequel elle perd
d'ailleurs des fans des fortunes
considérables
et puis aussi elle s'entoure de d'amis
mais d' amis ies n'est ce pas comme
madame de polignac ou comme la
ravissante petite princesse de lamballe
dont elle fait la surintendante de sa
maison à tel point même que tout le
monde va finir par jaser à versailles on
se dit que marie antoinette et ses amis
préfèrent les jeux saphique à tout autre
chose
elle n'hésitait jamais à contrevenir à
l'étiquette quand celle-ci s'opposer à
ses sentiments ses désirs
inspiré par les écrits de rousseau elle
restait parfois debout avec son
entourage
juste pour admirer le lever du jour
[Musique]
marie antoinette à même de recréer
l'atmosphère idyllique de son enfance en
rénovant le petit trianon un petit
palais attaché à versailles loup et
soutint l'inclination de la reine pour
le plaisir et pour quiconque pouvait
apaiser ces changements d'humeur mais la
conduite de marie antoinette reine de
france étaient jugées inconvenantes et
jugement et railleries fleurir dans la
presse française des pamphlets
diffamatoire l'accusé ainsi que ses amis
d'avoir un comportement obscène
le roi qui cherche évidemment à se faire
pardonner de les dire de sa balourdise
ou de ses maladresses avec cette petite
reine qui est belle le fragiles comme
comme un petit tanagra est bien le roi
lui cèdent toutes ses caprices
elle veut qu'il lui construise un petit
palais lui construire à trianon il
éponge ses dettes de jeu et lui cède
absolument tous ses caprices parce qu'il
a beaucoup à se faire pardonner la
maison de la reine comptait 500
personnes écoutaient 4 millions de
livres par an
ce luxe n'était cependant pas une
exception et ce style de vie existait
bien avant son arrivée
les soeurs du roi dépenser sans compter
tout comme ses frères ainsi que leurs
femmes et leurs enfants
mais ce sont les dépenses de marie
antoinette qui étaient épinglés et relié
directement au déficit grandissant
mais que représente et elle par rapport
à celle que la guerre à venir allaient
coûter à la france au début de de la vie
de marie-antoinette en france tout le
monde l'applaudît tout le monde là clame
elle est belle quand elle va à paris et
fait sensation mais une belle sensation
et puis progressivement on va se dire
que elle finit par coûter cher au trésor
royal puisqu'elle a des moeurs en effet
on écrit des pamphlets comme le journal
le talon rouge de la reine et c'est dans
lesquels ont décrit des scènes
absolument abominable
on dit qu'elle se fait peindre des
tableaux à trianon avec des femmes
énervé donc on commença à jaser à se
dire que cette reine n'est peut-être pas
aussi intéressante qu'on aurait pu
l'imaginer
le frère de marie antoinette l'empereur
joseph ii se rendit en mission à
versailles pour sauver le mariage royal
les médecins pensaient que le roi
souffrait d'un dysfonctionnement sexuel
appelé phimosis les avis divergeaient
quant à la nécessité qu'il subisse une
opération pour y remédier mais louis
s'ils refusaient catégoriquement
joseph 2 pensait quant à lui que les
difficultés du couple était simplement
dû à un manque d'expérience dans le
domaine sexuel
personne ne sut jamais ce qui s'était
passé mais il sembla que quelque chose
avait changé après la visite de
l'empereur marie antoinette fut
enceintes au printemps suivant et les
deux épouses
les braire bientôt la naissance d'une
fille marie-thérèse charlotte après la
naissance du premier enfant
effectivement gelé dire on a une fusion
qui est enfin réalisé et qui est bon je
crois partagée de là de l'autre côté la
relation entre le roi et la reine de vin
harmonieuse après la naissance de leur
premier enfant
ils en auront trois autres le dauphin
louis joseph suivi d'un autre
louis-charles leur quatrième enfant une
petite fille appelée sophie ne vécut pas
assez longtemps pour fêter son premier
anniversaire le roi et la reine jouit
ainsi d'une brève période de calme il
avait surmonté un défi majeur rempli
leur devoir en donnant naissance à un
héritier et vivait à présent une
relation amoureuse plein de respect
[Musique]
mais cette réussite sur le plan
personnel n'allait pas suffire à éviter
les troubles politiques prêts à
enflammer paris et toute la nation
[Musique]
l'organisation sociale qui régissait le
système politique français du 14e ou
xviiie siècle divisait la société en
trois ordres
le clergé la noblesse et le tiers état
c'est à dire les autres ou le reste de
la population ce qui différait de
l'ancien ordre féodal c'est que petit à
petit le pouvoir politique s'était
concentrée dans les mains de
quelques-uns et avait fait place à une
monarchie absolue
la france est dans une monarchie absolue
de droit divin et la france a perdu sur
le plan européen
sa prééminence depuis 1763 c'est à dix
depuis la fin de la guerre de sept ans à
l'issue de laquelle elle a perdu ses
colonies et elle a surtout perdu son aux
côtés d' arbitres des relations
européennes la monarchie française n'est
plus aussi sémillante qu'elles ne
l'étaient sous sous louis xiv
tout était rigoureux tout était de bien
ordonné entre temps on avait eu déjà un
peu de de libéralisme avec la régence où
les parlements avait repris un peu de
pouvoir ensuite ya eu louis 15 qui au
début de son règne a été louis le bien
aimé mais qui a fini comme étant
véritablement louis le détester donc
tout simplement la monarchie déjà on a
un coût dont elle loue 16 avec
19 ans quand il monta sur le trône or il
eu à faire face à d'énormes
responsabilités le gouvernement était
profondément endetté et l'hostilité au
despotisme monarchique atteignait son
comble on pensait généralement que le
roi était ennuyeux paresseux et sous
l'emprise de sa fan des découvertes
relativement récente remettent en cause
cette vision louis saez était un homme
qui mettait son intelligence au service
de tous les domaines de l'état en outre
jusqu'au début de la révolution
son épouse n'exerçait quasiment aucune
influence politique
mais tout le monde est d'accord pour
dire que louis saez étaient de caractère
indécis une fois devenu roi
il choisit comme conseiller et premiers
ministres jean frédéric phélippeau
compte de maurepas qui fit nommer
charles gravier compte de vergennes aux
affaires étrangères et turgot aux
finances
maurepas qui plaçait sa popularité
personnelle au dessus des besoins de la
france domine à la première partie du
règne
il manipule à le jeune roi afin que
celui ci approuve des mesures qui
allaient à l'encontre des intérêts du
pays
préparant ainsi le lit de la révolution
louis saez avait son mentor qui était le
compte de mou repas auquel il a avoué
une confiance inébranlable jusqu'à la
mort de celui-ci en 1781 en dehors de
maurepas louis saez avait également une
grande confiance en son ministre des
affaires étrangères qui était le compte
de vergennes le conseil royal était
affaiblie par des propositions
contradictoires tandis que le roi
réclamer davantage de réformes
financières pour régler la crise
intérieure
son ministre des affaires étrangères le
pressaient de se lancer dans une
entreprise coûteuse la guerre
d'indépendance américaine
les
sujet colons britanniques s'opposait
depuis des années aux impôts exigés par
la couronne
mais il manquait d'armes et d'alliés
dans leur combat pour se dégager de la
tutelle de la grande bretagne la
résistance des américains au roi
d'angleterre avait la faveur des
français
certains américains comme franklin tous
et jefferson ou ces gens là viennent en
france pour demander de l'aide pour que
les treize colonies puisse se libérer du
joug anglais dans le nouveau monde est
long il se dit tiens je vais les aider
parce que je ce faisant je vais faire un
pied de nez à l'angleterre qui nous a
pris après le traité de paris de la
guerre de sept ans avec son grand père
louis 15 qui nous a pris toutes nos
colonies donc c'est une manière de de
vengeance se dissimulait en acceptant de
participer à cette guerre de libération
des colonies américaines turgot le
prévint que si la france entrait dans
cette guerre les chances de réformer le
système financier serait réduite à néant
le plan de redressement de turgot qui
incluait la création de nouveaux impôts
le rendit impopulaire tout comme son
opposition à la guerre il fut démis au
bout de deux ans son successeur jacques
necker assura que si l'on faisait des
économies la france pourrait venir au
secours des américains sans augmenter
les impôts
benjamin franklin se rendit à versailles
pour obtenir le soutien des français
louis saez signent un traité l'alliance
militaire
en 1778 avec les américains et la france
entra dans la guerre d'indépendance
américaine
le soutien des français fut décisif il
force à l'armée britannique à se rendre
lors de la bataille de yorktown en 1780
et les dernières troupes anglaises
khiter new york
en 1783 louis saez n'aurait jamais dû
laisser son armée participé à cette
guerre les soldats qui avaient participé
à la guerre d'indépendance américaine
rentrée en france et ratant terre
comment les chefs de la résistance avait
pris en main leur destin s'est libéré de
l'oppression du roi d'angleterre et
avait institué un système politique tout
à fait différent
le système financier de l'ancien régime
déjà très affaibli par la guerre de sept
ans atteignait le point de rupture
en 1783 le déficit était tellement
important que le pays était au bord de
la faillite
la france l'avait emporté sur
l'angleterre et les états unis devenait
un état libre certes mais les caisses du
royaume avait été épuisé par cette
guerre d'amérique et louis saez s'est
trouvé dans un état d'anxiété énorme en
ce qui concernait les finances du
royaume car on était proche de la
banqueroute
la situation empirait avec necker qui
plutôt que d'augmenter les impôts
empruntait pour payer les dettes
luis saez le démis de ses fonctions et
le remplaça par charles alexandre de
calonne celui ci augmente à les dépenses
publiques pour acheter un moyen de
sortir le pays de ses dettes
ce fut encore un échec aussi le roi
convoque at-il l'assemblée des notables
en 1787 pour discuter d'une nouvelle
réforme fiscale révolutionnaire proposé
par callum
lui sait s'entourer de ministre c'est
qu'il en aura d des quantités et
notamment de son ministre il s'appelle
calonne mais qui est un ministre
révolutionnaire avant l'heure si je puis
dire puisque calonne envisage lui déjà
de supprimer les droits à la noblesse et
au clergé c'est à dire que ces gens là
seraient obligés de payer des impôts
comme le tiers état évidemment c c'est
une chose qui passera pas
[Musique]
durant cette décennie marie entre la
traîne de la famille habsbourg devint un
bouc émissaire bien utile pour endosser
tous les maux du royaume ces grossesses
qui succédait à 10 années d'infertilité
développeurs les rumeurs d'infidélités
des pamphlets calomniateurs circulait
narrant les fresques qu'on lui
attribuait avec ses nombreux amants
parmi eux il y avait même son beau frère
le comte d'artois en réalité marie
antoinette était d'un tempérament plutôt
chaste
elle appréciait d'avoir des admirateurs
et d'être courtisé mais repoussait les
entreprises de véritables séduction en
avance sur son temps elle abandonna
l'habitude de porter un épais maquillage
et de se poudrer outrageusement le
visage
[Musique]
le penchant de la reine pour un mode de
vie plus simple et plus retirés alimenta
aussi la contreverse à cette époque le
hameau de la reine avec ça ferme sa
laiterie et son moulin fut reconstruit
comme un refuge à l'écart du style de
vie bien réglée de la cour c'était une
retraite rustique conçu pour évoquer un
village de paysans est située dans une
partie reculée des jardins du trianon à
l'intérieur du parc de versailles
depuis des années les fermes modèles
étaient très à la mode dans
l'aristocratie
mais le moment était très mal choisi les
dépenses de la reine était mise en
question et il est vrai qu'elle n'avait
pas notablement diminué malgré les
difficultés financières que connaissait
le royaume après la guerre
d'indépendance américaine alors que les
finances étaient au plus bas
le roi et la reine possédait déjà les
résidences royales de compiègne
fontainebleau choisi la muette et marly
ils achetèrent rambouillet cette année
là puis saint cloud l'année suivante
l'acquisition de saint-cloud au nom de
la reine ne fit qu'ajouter à son
impopularité grandissante les souverains
savait-il à quel point le prix du pain a
augmenté
pour contrer la désapprobation
grandissante
louise vigée-lebrun reçu la commande de
portrait officiel de la reine
les précédents avaient été critiqués car
ils étaient trop ordinaire celui ci
mettait en valeur son rôle maternel
malheureusement la petite sophie mourut
pendant sa réalisation est dû être
effacées du tableau les campagnes contre
la reine commencèrent à produire leurs
effets les troubles politiques
grandissant le ressentiment public se
concentra sur elle pour la première fois
elle fut reçue très fraîchement dans
paris la mort de maurepas en 1780 marqua
le début du règne personnel de louis
saez sa décision de ne pas avoir de
nouveau premier ministre allait avoir de
graves conséquences
en fait les souffrances des français et
la menace de banqueroute ne pouvait être
plus longtemps ignorés et il était tout
simplement impossible d'attendre que
passe la crise financière en préservant
un système dépassé de privilèges
aristocratique
le roi ne voulait pas abandonner son
pouvoir absolu et il avait besoin que
l'aristocratie prenne sa part du fardeau
des impôts il espérait quand s'en
remettant à l'assemblée nationale il
pourrait court circuiter le parlement et
faire approuver sa nouvelle législation
il y à des réformes structurelles qui
sont absolument indispensables pour
assurer l'avenir réformes structurelles
par exemple l'égalité fiscale
cette fois le roi a été résolu il misait
tout son capital politique sur le succès
de cette dernière proposition un nouvel
impôt qu'on a appelé la subvention
territoriales c'est un poète est
intéressant dans la mesure où il voulait
être un impôt égalitaire c'était un
impôt sur les terres qu'elles soient
roturière noble ou appartenant au clergé
quand l' assemblée de notables se réunit
en janvier 1787
le roi à travers son nouveau ministre
des finances charles alexandre de
calonne présenta les chiffres du déficit
et introduisit un groupe de réforme
parmi lesquels une taxe sur la terre et
une taxe sur les propriétés des nobles
et du clergé les notables qui n'avait
jamais réellement été au courant de la
situation financière furent choqués et
pensèrent que calonne était le seul à
blâmer les réformes furent presque
unanimement repoussé
jusque là la monarchie avait contrôlé la
politique fiscale à sa manière en secret
de façon hiérarchique sans que la
population n'ait un regard sur les
comptes ou l'établissement d'impôts
quand la nouvelle se répandit que la
nation était aux prises avec un déficit
ingérable secret à l'image d'une
institution en faillite et corrompu sous
bien des aspects il décide de convoquer
à zéro c'est à dire de faire élire des
députés de tout venant de toute la
france jusqu'à versailles pour montrer
dans quel état se trouve véritablement
le royaume
louis saez qui avait soutenu très
sincèrement le programme de réformes de
calonne vécu son refus par les notables
et le parlement comme un échec personnel
il ne se remit jamais de cette
expérience démoralisante on pense même
que le rejet de ses propositions
provoqua en lui un changement si profond
qu'on peut parler de deux louis celui
d'avant février 1787 et celui d'après il
renonce à aux longues parties de chasse
et aux grandes quantités de nourriture
et de boisson qui l'engloutît 7
auparavant
de nombreux historiens voit les mois qui
suivirent comme le début d'une période
de dépression
le roi étant atteints psychologiquement
la reine marie-antoinette entra dans
l'arène politique
quand joseph de appris que sa soeur
pouvait enfin exercer son influence il
lui envoya des instructions pour qu'elle
favorise les intérêts de l'autriche
mais il était trop tard la reine qui
avait à présent passer plus d'années à
versailles qu'à vienne était dégager de
l'emprise familiale elle avait construit
sa propre famille et les souffrances
qu'elle avait enduré durant toutes ces
années lui avait donné un courage et une
maturité qu'on ne lui connaissait pas
auparavant
calomnie scandale infortunés erreurs
avaient entamé le pouvoir de la
monarchie la convocation des états
généraux indiquer clairement à quel
point elle était devenue faible
la france avait atteint un tournant
dangereux
après 14 ans de règne le régime est en
phase terminale le roi n'a pas d'autre
choix que de promettre une réunion des
états généraux
cette concession symbolise sa défaite
c'est précisément la suspension de ce
corps législatif qui définissait
l'ancien régime
il avait été abandonné par louis xiv en
16 114 et les rois bourbon avait pendant
cent soixante quinze ans affirmé qu'il
possédait l'autorité absolue ce qui
éliminait toute nécessité de convoquer
les états généraux
si louis saez fille cette promesse
c'est qu'ils ne pouvaient que constater
que la monarchie était en train de
perdre cette autorité absolue la
révolution française elle est éclatée
douze mois plus tard
mais comment est né ce changement
soudain dans la conscience collective
des français 8 août 10 788 la réunion
inaugurale des états généraux est
officiellement annoncée par le roi
celui ci détient toujours l'autorité qui
lui permet d'influencer le scrutin il a
bien compris que les privilégiés le haut
clergé et la noblesse refuseront
obstinément civray d'abandonner les
privilèges qui leur ont été consentis au
fil des siècles la stratégie royal et
d'affaiblir le pouvoir de la noblesse en
renforçant le tir et a perçu comme un
allié du souverain on suggère donc de
doubler le nombre de députés du tiers
état
26 août 10 788 jacques necker et de
nouveau appelé à regret par marie
antoinette pour être directeur général
des finances dans un effort pour apaiser
le peuple 27 décembre 1788
le doublement du tiers-état a été
approuvée par le roi et ouvre une
question chaudement débattu
les députés voteront t-il pas record
auquel cas le tiers état bénéficierait
d'une plus grande représentation ou
séparément
janvier 1789 cette année là l'hiver fut
le plus sévère dont on se souvint les
pauvres souffrait à faire pitié
le prix du pain grimpa accélérant une
propagande encore plus haineuse contre
la reine on l'accuse en particulier de
faire monter délibérément les prix des
émeutes dues aux difficultés financières
éclatent parmi les troupes du roi
nourrissant la méfiance public envers le
gouvernement
un des conseillers du roi qui est
malesherbes dit à ce moment-là à louis
saez cyr donner une constitution au
royaume avant que vous n'y soyez obligé
louis saez n'a pas écouté malesherbes
il s'en est suivi la réunion des états
généraux et les états généraux se sont
proclamés assemblée constituante c'est à
dire une assemblée qui devait donner une
constitution à la france 4 mai 1789 la
procession d'ouverture des états
généraux royal traverse versailles d'une
église à l'autre mais les réactions de
la population
marc la diminution du respect accordé à
la famille royale 5 mai 1789 11 200
députés se rassemblent à versailles pour
les états généraux le roi prend la
parole suivi de jacques necker
comme il n'y a aucune directive sur la
manière de voter le tiers état est libre
d'en débattre
bientôt les classes sociales supérieures
deviennent leurs cibles whissell était
convaincu qu'il y aurait qu on voterait
par ordre c'est à dire qu'ils auraient
une voie pour le clergé une voix pour la
noble c'est une voie pour le théâtre et
arts dans ce cas là n'auraient deux voix
de majorité forcément et bien non parce
que le tiers état se révoltent attirant
ainsi avec lui quelques membres du
clergé même quelques quelques
aristocrates quelques nobliaux qui
viennent rejoindre le tiers état
notamment quand je dis des nobliaux
philippe d'orléans le futur philippe
égalité qui va monter à l'assaut avec le
tiers état donc c'est un petit peu la
panique parce que on réclame non le vote
par tête de pipe et non plus par ordre
dans le même temps louis saez est
préoccupé par des sujets douloureux
en mai le dauphin était mourant 4 juin
louis-joseph meurt le coeur brisé
ses parents se retire au château de
marly pour deux semaines de deuil
pendant lesquelles sont prises des
décisions cruciales liées au tiers et à
17 juin dans un mouvement de rejet des
ordres les députés du tiers état
appuyé par quelques membres issus du
clergé se proclame assemblée nationale
ils disent représenter la volonté du
peuple et avoir l'intention de rédiger
une nouvelle constitution
il invite les membres des autres ordres
à se joindre à eux ou à être ignorée
l'éloignement du roi et son chagrin le
rendre vulnérable aux pressions
conservatrices de ses frères necker
défend que des concessions sont
nécessaires pendant que les frères du
roi sont partisans d'une ligne dure
on dit alors que marie antoinette a des
prémonitions et voit le pays allait à sa
ruine 20 juin la salle où ils ont
l'habitude de se réunir leur est enfermé
les députés du tiers état se retrouve
dans un jeu de paume tout proche et la
journée se termine par le fameux serment
du jeu de paume un acte de défiance
ignorant les pouvoirs de la monarchie 23
juin louis saez propose des réformes qui
sont rejetés par l'assemblée
2 juillet le roi capitule et ordonne aux
ordres de la noblesse et du clergé de se
joindre aux tiers état le même jour ils
envoient les troupes royales à paris il
désire simplement rétablir l'ordre
mais la rumeur se répandre à travers la
ville qu'il a l'intention de dissoudre
l'assemblée
11 juillet necker qui maintient qu'il
faut se rapprocher du peuple est
destitué une seconde fois et remplacé
par le très conservateur baron de
breteuil
à ce moment le roi a nommé est démis
plus de directeur des finances que l'on
peut en compter 12 juillet la démission
de necker est prise pour un outrage
public la population entre en ébullition
à la suite de ce conflit politique qui
ébranle le régime 13 juillet à paris les
troupes royales doivent répondre à un
incident mineur et les événements
tournent à la violence ce qui nuit
encore davantage à la réputation du roi
le bruit court que les soldats en
délibérément attaqué la population la
loi de la rue est prête à occuper le
terrain
[Applaudissements]
14 juillet la population prend d'assaut
la prison de la bastille symbole de
l'oppression
elle s'empare des armes et de la poudre
pour se protéger contre le gouvernement
louis saez est allé à la chasse
le jour du 14 juillet c'est bien que sur
son petit carnet de bord quand on le lit
on voit rien à la date du 14 juillet bon
il est vrai que dans la nuit un de ses
officiers qui est monsieur de la
rochefoucauld liancourt se précipitent
demande à ce qu'on réveille le roi et
lui explique que ben ma foi ça c'est
paris est à feu et à sang et qu'on a
pris la bastille et le roi lui dit c'est
une émeute et on connaît la réplique de
la rochefoucauld liancourt qu'il est non
sire c'est une révolution
[Musique]
la place qu'accorde de l'histoire à la
mémoire de louis saez et de marie
antoinette est trop petit pour refléter
le caractère épique de leur vie et de
leur époque
peut-être sont-ils le roi et la reine de
france les plus mal compris de
l'histoire marie-antoinette dont les
excès sont devenus une fable est souvent
considérée comme étant la cause de la
révolution française
mais la légende éclipse la véritable
histoire la menace autrichienne était
une obsession dans l'esprit du peuple
la méfiance envers l'ancien régime et le
ressentiment grandissant
la reine née autrichienne devint une
cible facile pour le peuple en colère
sa réputation se construisit sur des
années de calomnies de la part de la
presse française marie antoinette
n'était pas exempte de fautes naïve et
égocentrique
elle cède à la frivolité pendant que son
peuple souffrait pourtant ses péchés
étaient minces comparé au châtiment qui
lui fut infligée le roi était beaucoup
plus intelligent et plus déterminés que
le portrait qu'on en fait généralement
cette image celui du roi paresseux du
roi dominé par sa femme du roi même
adipeux tout ceci relève en quelque
sorte des images d'epinal ça n'a rien à
voir avec la réalité déjà physiquement
si vous voulez le roi mesure près d'un
mètre 90
alors comment le sait-on des tout
simplement parce qu' il existe aux
archives nationales
le patron de la robe du sacre et donc il
suffit de transposer si vous voulez les
pieds les pouces qui sont mentionnés
ciblée sur la coupe de cet habit pour
avoir effectivement les réelle dimension
du souverain
si l'on en croit les récits louis saez
était aimable sensible et intelligent
il prenait très au sérieux les veut
solennel qu'il avait prononcé devant
dieu et son pays d'être un bon roi il
était dévoué à son destin et à sa reine
il semblait un homme bien meilleur que
louis xiv ou louis 15 et pourtant son
règne a marqué la fin de la monarchie
pourquoi les causes des désordres
politiques qui éclatèrent en 1789 était
bien ancien la responsabilité évidente
des précédents valois et bourbon est
souvent négligée mais finalement c'est
le caractère conventionnel de louis saez
et son absence de décision pour
envisager mettre en oeuvre une solution
qui ont été considérés comme la cause de
la chute de la royauté le roi voulait
opérer des changements dans l'ancien
système
mais ils ne pensaient qu'à l'abolition
des privilèges c'est vision
conservatrice l'empêchait d'envisager
une autre politique
son incapacité à choisir un premier
ministre et l'origine de la plupart de
ces problèmes sans réforme financière ni
administrative
la france se retrouva en pleine
révolution
un déficit désastreux les idéaux des
lumières renforcée par la déclaration
d'indépendance des états unis et la
vague d'hostilité envers la famille
royale sont les facteurs qui une fois
combiné abolir la tradition française de
la règle absolue
l'érosion de l'autorité royale mena à
des querelles de factions et finalement
à l'effondrement d'institutions qui
avait réguler la vie de la nation depuis
huit siècles
dans les mois qui suivirent la
démolition de la bastille l'inefficacité
du roi et l'impopularité de la reine sa
paire la monarchie en tant
qu'institution les tentatives pour
étouffer la révolution échouèrent le
renversement des rôles entre le roi et
la reine qui débuta dans les derniers
jours de l'ancien régime se poursuivit à
travers le tumulte de la révolution
louis saez devint alors le roi dont se
souvient l'histoire et bt dépendant
vacillant et la reine de france pris de
plus en plus de pouvoir d'abord dans un
effort pour restaurer la monarchie
puis dans une tentative désespérée pour
sauver sa famille au cours de notre
prochain épisode consacré à louis saez
et à la révolution française
nous assisterons à la fin de la
monarchie et à celle du couple royal
après que ce dernier n'ait saisi
l'ampleur de la situation que trop tard
la tentative de fuite ne les mènera pas
plus loin que varennes et la suite des
événements ne tournera pas à l' avantage
du roi ni à celui de la reine